two and a half minutes left and like
Philadelphia scores a touchdown on a New
England I mean they're only up by five
right now so I mean it could come back
and they're doing the official review on
whether or not it was it's a legit
touchdown uh okay uh I am oh my god I'm
so excited for a fitting or a 30-second
TV spot alright so that gave us like
this really cool like like brief glimpse
with Iron Man's armor like Iron Man suit
I don't know that the guys caught it I
know how many of you guys saw it but
there's this point where Iron Man suit
is literally just coming up his body and
like as soon as I saw that I was like
dude I really hope other people saw it
I'm pretty sure Charlie an emergency
awesome saw it because I the guy makes
videos on this kinda stuff all the time
Charlie save some of the pie for the
rest of us man but nonetheless it is it
was it was it was crazy like it was it
was really funny to see that because I
was like okay so that means we're
getting like one of two types of armor
here or we're getting both alright my
initial gut reaction was okay so that
means that we're getting like the
extremis armor that was my first initial
thought I was like okay the suits
basically coming on like it's it's you
know what's coming up on it stuff but
the more I thought about it I was like
that's not how that works like the the
extremis armor the actual like under
armor itself like comes out of the
hollows of Tony Stark's bones but like
the actual suit like still shows up he
just has like a psychic connection to it
but the actual like the suit is still
like it still relies on tech the only
other version of his suit that does not
rely on tech that still functions that
capacity is endo sim and I think that's
what we're getting I think we're getting
the endosymbiont Oh sim suit as we saw
it in superior Iron Man so here's the
deal
suppose you guys who don't know the endo
sim suit was an armor or was was a type
of armor created by Iron Man which I've
got videos on like all the armors of
Iron Man but it was a type of armor made
by Iron Man that was based off the
symbiote technology like venom carnage
those guys the whole idea behind this
was that the suit would basically
respond to the mind of Tony Stark like
it would respond to his you know mental
commands and basically it would just
manifest itself it would literally just
in case Tony Stark so he could have it
any time he wanted it to either it could
be on his physicals like it would be a
part of his physical body or like it
wouldn't the suit could like like he
would have like this fake this this
it would look like he wouldn't have a
cover on his face but it was actually
just a transparent material but the idea
was that the suit could just manifest
itself onto him and he could have it at
any point in time the difference is that
the suit was more like a silver and blue
dude it looked badass to do was it was
like the sweetest looking suit that
Ironman ever had it was like the
Lamborghini of suits it was it was it
was it was it was the beastliest Ironman
suit that there ever was if ever there
was an Ironman suit that was it it's the
most Ironman of all the Iron Man suits
that Ironman ever made it looks super
cool but the fact remains here that
that's what I think we're basically
getting here now the question is if it's
not based on symbiote technology because
the citiots haven't been introduced into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe yet then
what's it going to be based on well my
money's on nanotechnology I don't know
what else it would be it would just be
like super small machines that 20 Stark
made and and it would make sense I mean
it would fall in line with Stark
Industries like well this is just a
whole new suit that I've done and it's
basically just you know design in such a
way that you know it responds to my
mental commands or something along those
lines it could be based off the
extremist attack because the extremis as
it was done in Iron Man 3 is for the
most part pretty similar to how it is in
Marvel Comics extremest was basically
designed to be a kind of healing factor
esque
situation and that says that it would
like enhance the abilities of people and
again all that was predicated on Captain
America it all comes back to Captain
America the first super soldier
everybody was just trying to find a way
to make a new super soldier and they
believed extremists would be the ones
that would that would you know though
that would be the ability to make that
happen of course it fell into the wrong
hands different things like that and the
movie it fell in the hands of what does
it Aldrich Killian or whatever it was
and then you know people were using it
to like explode and things like that but
the fact remains here um the the basis
them the idea behind it and the purpose
had served was still pretty much the
same it's just the implementation of the
extremest tech changed over the years
with regards to you know Marvel Comics
it caparison to how it was used in the
MCU but regardless I think the in
dosimetry getting an infinity war and if
we are that's gonna be amazing I don't
thing we're gonna see it much after that
I think that honestly I think Robert
Downey jr. is gonna die and if it
anymore you know that's let's talk buy
that for a second who's gonna die in
infinity war we know black widows
getting a movie so it's not gonna be her
Steve Rogers probably won't die we know
that uh you know like like you know
spider-man is getting a new movie no
black pants there's probably gonna get a
second movie um may twelve ition vision
is probably gonna die in infinity war
cuz he's only gonna have the mind stone
ripped out of his head but all that's
gonna be is like avert it's gonna be the
equivalent of what happened like when he
lost the brain patterns of Wonder Man
and became an all white Android if you
don't know what that means don't worry
about it not a great big huge steel it
was an attempt by Maul what a kind of
reboot vision where you had like the
relationship between like vision and
Scarlet Witch mama thought it had run
its course and it grown old so because
of the fact that vision was based on the
mental patterns of a previously thought
dead superhero when those mental
patterns were like eliminated and vision
was like taken apart when they put him
back together Simon Simon Williams
Wonder Man the guy that the mental
patterns are based on wouldn't let them
use his mental patterns again because
the guy was just kind of being a dick
and so like so the Oh vision was just
kind of like this Android with like no
personality whatsoever and like that was
it you know and and it was like are you
white now you know and it was it was it
was weird it was kind of weird thing but
the fact remains I mean I can't think of
very many people dying I mean I pray to
God Santos doesn't die please for the
love of God Kevin Feige do not kill
thanos like there's so much you could do
with this character you know this man
you've been reading comic books forever
so like I really hope that we end up
seeing like you don't they Aniston them
survive which means to me I think I I
think Robert Downey jr. is done I think
he's ready to be finished with Iron Man
I think he's kind of like look I helped
to build the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I've been doing this for years and years
and years I'm ready to go ahead and just
like move on to something else like I'm
ready to move on to other projects and
so I I imagine him just kind of like
dying you know and just just calling it
a day I mean that I mean it also raises
other questions like who's gonna take
the Infinity Gauntlet from Thanos
because that's what happens to the
affinity gauntlet story like somebody
takes it from them so it's like like I
mean if that happens like like who's
gonna take it from them uh I don't know
I mean I would say probably spider-man
to be honest with you guys like I think
spider-man will be the one to get the
Infinity Gauntlet although I am waiting
for like this staredown oh dude okay so
like in Infinity Gauntlet no there's no
K there's this really cool moment
there's a I love getting
I love this okay there's this really
cool moment where like Thanos has like
wrecked everyone right like he's he's
wrecked everybody and like Captain
America is like the last man standing
and like Thanos has the Infinity
Gauntlet and like you know that I said
like backhanded Captain America's shield
to pieces he literally just slapped his
shield to pieces and like like you know
like Captain America just like marches
up on him you know and as and it like
stares him down and he's like he's like
you're a villain just like any other
villain I've ever faced you're no
different from any bad guys I've ever
fought before they're just gonna be so
cool because then people are gonna be
like yeah America captain freedom it's
gonna be it's gonna be pretty wild but
uh but no it's like the movies gonna
have man and I'm really excited there's
gonna be some great moments in this film
I am kind of getting tired of seeing
everybody running towards the screen at
what Conda what's on the other side of
that screen that's what I want to know
is it more of like those those falafels
or whatever it was you know the things
that they got the the shwarma that they
got from Avengers is it just like like
they're all the middle of battle and
then somebody's like hey guys there's
swarm over here they're all just like
let's go and they all just like beeline
towards the swarm cart you know if
somebody's serving you know like like
lemon ice is that what it is because I
mean I would do that or like dippin dots
do let me tell you something man like I
would if I were in the middle if I were
in the middle of the battle like that
you know if I mean if I was immortal sit
out of universe and Santos is invading
the earth
he's like attacking everybody and
somebody was like dude man like mrs.
Jenkins just got here man she's got
dippin dots I would be like dude man I
gotta go I'll cut you down later I would
race race over dude hmm this cost man I
would have race over and I would grab
some dippin dots see that was I would
grab the hell out of those dippin dots
dude I hate having the flu so bad this
sucks so bad oh my god anyway so uh so
yeah like I don't know I mean I think
that what we saw is Indo sim and like uh
probably a combination of Indo sim and
extremists in the sense that it is the
color and the the look the appearance of
the extremist suit
combined with the functionality of the
Indo Simtek and like how that worked
with regards to the suit being put on by
Tony Stark and and so on and so forth
but ya know I mean I'm really excited
like I'm pretty I'm pretty hyped either
way I mean infinity war
I think it's shaping up that it's gonna
be the one of the best movies like one
of the best comic book movies ever made
I mean there's just there's so much
possibility in terms of what could
happen there's so much possibility in
terms of what can go on I mean I don't
know it's it's it's God it's gonna be
wild uh I mean I'm curious let me know
down in the in the comments so I know
you guys are excited too I know you guys
know you guys are hyped to let me know
down in the comments what you guys think
about the whole idea of like the you
know the infinity war movie like what do
you think's gonna happen
let me know who you think is gonna die
because that's who I'm curious who do
you think is gonna die in infinity war
and I don't care if you think it's five
people if you think it's everyone like
and I don't mean the people that fail
it's like blinks half the life or the
universe out and then like it comes back
I mean know who's gonna die and then
like stay dead like who is not going to
come back after infinity war and
Avengers 4 is done like who's gone
forever let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section because I'm
kind of curious ah but anyway if you
guys are new here to comics explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace